how did Brad Pitt's brutal brawls and
Fight Club lead to his cameo in one of
the highest grossing R-rated movies of
all time stick around to find out Brad
Pitt is one of the most recognizable
actors in Hollywood having starred in
profitable pictures like World War Z
bester and Mr Smith and Ocean's 11. but
his highest grossing film ever doesn't
feature him in a leading role that honor
actually goes to Deadpool 2 which made
786 million dollars worldwide it's easy
to forget that Pitt was in Deadpool 2 at
all and if you blinked while watching it
you might have missed him as the
vanisher he has the power of total
invisibility but that doesn't stop him
from suffering a shocking fate in a
tragic parachuting accident
vanisher maybe the wind can't blow what
it can't see
[Music]
yes this is the only time pit actually
appears in the film he never says a word
obviously the gag is that no one
expected a star of pits caliber to join
the cast of Deadpool 2 for such a
minuscule role most film Productions
would be thrilled to have an a-lister
like him on board but director David
Leach subverted Expectations by giving
him a laughably brief Cameo so how did
this zany appearance come about as pit
explains a BBC Radio 1 in August 2022 he
and leech have a friendship that dates
all the way back to the fight club days
he explained Dave's an old friend of
mine he was my stunt double starting
with Fight Club and all the way up until
about 2004. and then he went off and
became a really good director which is
rare leech is best known now as a
director of adrenaline bumping films
like bullet train Fast and Furious
presents Hobson Shore and atomic blonde
but to reach his level of success within
the action genre leech first put a lot
of time into crafting coordinating and
Performing stunts aside from standing in
as Tyler Durden in the late 90s leech
performed stunt work in Blade and the
Matrix Reloaded but he still continued
to double for pit in films like the
Mexican Ocean's 11 and Mr and Mrs Smith
after some time however their careers
diverged leech pivots into assisting
with stone coordination in films like
Viva Vendetta and acted as the action
coordinator for X-Men Origins Wolverine
meanwhile Pitt starred in critically
acclaimed films like 12 Years a Slave
The Big Short and Once Upon a Time in
Hollywood the last of which finally got
simmer's Oscar however leech's
professional relationship with Peter's
recently come full circle during a press
event for Leeches bullet train in which
pit stars as a bumbling assassin ladybug
the actor discussed what it was like to
work with leech again saying he trained
me for those fights in a way he's
helping me develop the character now
he's a director with his own voice and
vernacular I'm serving him he's the boss
so there was a beautiful symmetry for
two old friends drawing a conversation
with leech and Pitt for brew America
leech happily noted our Fates took us in
different places and then they ended up
bringing us back together as
entertaining as it would be it's very
unlikely that Deadpool 3 will be what
unites leech and pits again for
outlandish battle sequences instead of
leech Sean Levy will be directing the
third Ryan Reynolds starring Deadpool
film and unless some kind of multiversal
plot device changes things pits run into
invisible X-Force member seems to be
over it's also unclear when Deadpool 3
will actually hit the big screen due to
the Dual writer an actor strikes within
Hollywood the release date is up in the
air that doesn't mean that the leech pit
collaborations are a thing of the past
though bullet train grossed over 239
million dollars at the global box office
on a budget of around 85 million dollars
with just no small feat is a testament
to the pair of successful work together
on and off camera